heard you guys need some pipes fixed or
cleaned or whatever angela special
repair man is here what what is this
shut up jakey
mom
wait wait what oh man no no no no just
do your work pretend mom's not here uh
that seems inappropriate give him a good
show my little entrepreneur
okay take it off
yeah good song choice shaky stripper's
only as good as a song
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh wow
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
didn't maintain 100 beats per minute and
the ambulance didn't arrive because
nobody called 9-1-1 so you lost him okay
he's dead anyone know what we do next
anybody rose
i have no idea anyone else we bury him
wrong and check for an organ donor card
if he has one we only have minutes to
harvest he has no wallet i checked he is
an organ donor he is yeah give me some
ice in a styrofoam bucket
here we go
we search for the organs where's the
heart the brush is hard i'm not feeling
well i need to sit down
are you okay
oh my god
oh my god what if we all get together
and help each other and hire a new guy
and then we all kill him but first we
take out like 100 000 life insurance
policy i bet you guys like that idea
don't you
i think that's what they're doing to me
i can't prove it but i wanted to see
their faces when i said it
i learned nothing
i don't know what that was uh they were
engaged mm-hmm
well
what are you doing what are you doing
uh in the foster home my hair was my
room
you know what you know what everybody's
looking at you right now
i'll have what she's having
be
prepared to be scared okay
okay
[Music]
the cinema of the unsettling is a
growing film movement
the most well-known film in the genre is
an hour-long shot of a squirrel with
diarrhea
okay
[Music]
is that my grandmother
what's the story there is no story yeah
it seems like there isn't a narrative
maybe the filmmaker realized that even
narrative is comforting
the hell is going on here okay i think
we've seen enough but you you can turn
it off now yeah
yeah kill it
turn it on thank you get in my car
you interviewing for the sales job too
no you're interviewing for it i'm
getting it well i wouldn't be so sure
about that i mean i've been working here
12 weeks that's a full season of
homeland a ton of things can happen in
that amount of time as we've seen
i'm ralph
brawfall
rolf all
sounds kind of like raw doll go to hell
there he is
come on buddy
let's do this sorry ralph goes first you
don't compare when you're with the rolf
you're literally rolling on the laughing
floor ah nice
rolf is my best friend and he is the man
cool calm and collected 24 7. just try
and rattle rolf i dare you
such a sweet guy and this is my
workspace this is it check that out you
smell it
uh-huh as you can smell there's a lot of
different odors going on in here
so you have an office and a workspace i
do you know i just i cannot create in
the same space that i conduct business
i'm sure that you're the same with your
doodles smell
it's fire uh-huh bond fire
then love this one james bond fire i am
bonfire james bond fire michael scott
i get frustrated or irritated or
angry i come up here and i just smell
all my candles and i just poof goes away
just like that just like that so this is
the master bedroom and uh these walls
they used to be like white like an
asylum so i wanted it to be softer so i
had it painted in eggshell white guess
what
white and eggshell white are exactly the
same color
exactly i thought you said that you were
going to tidy things up well
i shave on you
what a cute bench thanks that's my bed
jan has uh some space issues so i curl
up on that puppy
really cause
seems pretty narrow
and short it's actually a lot bigger
than it seems look at this
see
he fits perfectly
let me get this straight
you lost all of it
all your winnings
a hundred and fifty thousand dollars but
to economy but investment you mean to
tell me no one wanted an energy drink
for asian homosexuals they did not
and you got half a million of these
well i gotta try it i wouldn't oh come
on what's the heart
[Music]
flavor of that
penis
the coconut is pretty subtle andrew it's
time for you to go home
you're better than this
yeah i know
everyone's better than this because this
is the worst thing i have ever seen
oh why they had coconut i miss original
well if he's not gonna make it at least
we should go ahead and
eat the cake
yeah
i for one love the corners
why did i just do that
it's not even that good
i don't even look i don't even want it
i had cake for lunch
no you know what i've been good i
deserve this
what am i doing come on
hey
no
oh
no
hey where do i park i'm the valet you
have to give me your car uh you know
what i'm going to i'm the valet you have
to give me your car probably okay
no
i think it's probably better than the
valet you have to do it's a gift it's a
finicky get out of your car
get out
you have a good time at the thing it's a
little tricky
[Music]
self-defense is not some fun boxing
match okay this is about escaping with
your life so
strike scream and run
all right let's try it
that may have been my fault what the
hell toby
you